do what you're doing and go out and do
all these things with your life and like
take your career to the next level
everything's kind of handed to them
that's not every case but God walk down
here telling me all I got to do is strip
my kid naked beat him a couple times
with iron and he'll be Michael Jackson
[Laughter]
[Music]
who's the biggest Michael Jackson fan in
here oh I got him tattered on me
was he bad yeah absolutely was he a
thriller to watch absolutely did he like
them pretty young things absolutely
absolutely yeah he liked women yeah
yes there's a really rare recording that
I've never heard where he's talking
about some stuff that he went through
with his dad and it's pretty graphic oh
we all know this but let's go you do I
mean oh yeah Joe Jackson abused the [__]
out of all of his kids he goes into
detail in this in this recording and
I've never heard this in my life I
thought I heard everything jam on it
then come on Jam On It come on man come
on dude give it to me
come on
surely oil you down
so when when the flip of the end of the
ironing card hits you which is you know
you ever heard this just like me dying
and use your flips all over his face and
back everywhere and I always hear my
mother but no bill you're gonna kill him
you're gonna kill him now so they all
them down they would oil them down okay
there's nothing I can do but what's the
point of that
what the ironing board
what's the ironing cord
on it and he'd be like everybody like
like looking at your heart like don't
you mess up you know and I'm like oh God
somewhere at this show
we hear this car coming it's pretty long
but that's like one third of it uh
that's crazy he made him strip naked to
oil up his whole body just to hit him
with a cord that just sounds like Asian
parenting guys I'm just thinking about
my past here
am I uh all right here's a hot take
right my my brother so
um we all we got our asses beat to play
piano that was normal like you play the
wrong chords you get [__] up right so
it sounds like some Joe Jackson [__] my
brother confronted my dad and said you
[__] me up because I didn't play the
right chords and he goes you guys should
have [__] me up harder you know what a
great pianist I would have been you let
me quit huh and then I was so
mind-blowing I was like most of us
confront our parents of our trauma and
tell them to apologize my brother's such
a psychopath he was telling my parents
like you should have not you should have
beat me harder so I never would have
gave up piano know I would have been a
great pianist
he really meant that yeah you know I was
like what the [__] I kind of I kind of
relate to that with my possible boxing
in a way of like my dad always said if
you don't want a box anymore that's fine
you have your choice like he's not gonna
force it on me right I kind of had a
little thing of like why didn't you just
push a little bit why'd you let me quit
yo let me hold on to it a little bit
more you know what I'm saying but uh uh
not not now he's he's nuts yeah you know
what I'm saying but damn I was like I
can't wait to tell my parents what's up
so they can apologize and I'll be like
and and that's why I don't like piano
because you guys hurt my feelings you
know but then my brother was a [__]
psychopath like he was just like
straight up I can't believe you let me
quit I was just a child how good was
your brother that piano yeah I never
heard him play
but my parents or maybe he did I don't
remember but he by the time because he's
12 years older than me so by the time I
started playing and doing all that stuff
he wasn't in the house no more he was
going to boarding schools and your
brother's actually crazy all around or
just this I don't know I guess I
understand that if let's say uh she was
just right on the cusp and was just like
just not number one you know what I mean
and didn't get the [__] first string
seat or some [__] like that and it's
like why don't you [__] push me hard
I could have been better but if he's
just another dude another Asian dude
playing the piano it's like yeah you
crazy he might be I just don't remember
yeah are you nice with it no I don't
even know how to read notes because this
is how I learned drugs and musical jeans
I got so scared
um to play the wrong notes I just
learned how to remember the song as fast
as possible so I pretend to read the
notes and then so then my dad started
noticing that I'm playing the song and I
didn't flip the page oh yeah so he's
like you're not reading the chords like
no and then afterwards I was like I
don't want to play anymore I'm too
scared like I get my ass beat like I
don't know yeah if it's fears associated
with that that's not good so I never
really learned how to play correctly
because I just learned how to memorize
real quick you're like Nick Cannon on
Drumline yeah pretty much you couldn't
but I didn't even get the Ryan's level
though because I'm out here playing When
the Saints Go Marching In and [__]
memorizing [__] Twinkle Twinkle
Little Star you know yeah Ryan's doing
like Flight of the Bumblebee Bossa Nova
remix with Christmas right oh you get
down the piano too it was [__] also a
genius my [__] was was the same thing
though like like the my teacher was this
strict Japanese dude it's always the
Japanese he would hold a like a huge
sharp and a pencil and he would hold it
above my hand and then I would look at
the music and play who was your piano
teacher are you sure it's not my dad
Paul Matsumoto it's not my dad and then
if I if I [__] up then he would just
go
and so that I would associate like the
ah ah bro yeah
yeah it's like that feeling of like in
my head now it's like there's like a I
can feel like the [__] prickles yeah
it's like weird but how did it transfer
into love because it's always been hate
it never was when it was piano lessons
for me I was like oh look I hated it for
eight years straight I didn't start
liking it until I I stopped having a
teacher oh see I never got to that level
I wasn't beat long enough I had eight
years of [__] like that like
different teachers that were all kind of
in that same mode you think pianist
would be like uh yeah you said penis
yeah you think they'd be nicer pick up
if they had cooler names than penis
nobody wants them yeah you pianist right
yeah it could have been it could have
just been pianoist yeah I feel like I
feel like I feel like that's what that's
what they're like getting pissed at
because they have that running joke you
said penis they're like I have a cooler
name I know why can't you be the key
master yeah there we go Rebrand pianist
what is it how you say it pianoist just
kidding penis no I didn't
it's good
guys
you one of them dick dudes did you ever
have to do the egg holding technique for
the perfect form no where they put two
two eggs on your chin and you have to
hold it there while you're playing
[Laughter]
no they would just like lift your wrist
up yeah but then like that was kind of
like damn yeah it was weird you couldn't
even start until you were in the form
yeah so it didn't even matter they were
like well you can't play it like that
you can't hang so I play like this
yeah that's minimalist I just know how
to do that
and that's it that's it that's all you
need if you're I feel like a lot of [__]
would have been like
[Music]
um I don't know like it's like top I
mean obviously top better without the
violence right but then I think more
people would have been creative if the
right teacher
taught like you know gave them that I'm
yeah for sure okay so I'm trying to put
this all together in my head so when I
taught kids during the summer
um I I wanted to expand the dance class
a little bit more so I like researched
like what can you do with dance how to
beat kids no uh but like how do you
utilize dance in a way these kids can um
get to know who they are through it
right and communicate so one of it was I
want you guys to improv and and do a
move for me that resembles anger right I
want to say anger
the [__] that I saw was crazy like some
kids would slap their own face and then
I'll be like okay wait oh [__] that's
commitment yeah yeah and they would tell
me about your relationship
for my dad's mad he does this they're
like
[Music]
it's not stripping naked putting oil on
it made me realize just [__] like
you just see the house then yeah
damn and then you're like do you want to
see that so I need I want to talk to
them about it and then I go okay well
I'm not a therapist or anything so I'm
gonna be like let's think about when you
feel this way what makes you snap out of
it is it like a hug is it like a scream
like let's work on that to just switch
it real quick so to hear that and I grew
up pretty like uh abused too so that's
tough but then the oiling is different
so I'm just like that oiling is weird no
he's being nice if his oils the cord
will slip off you know what I mean right
yeah make it softer mine was like no oil
but then it's like it's dry yeah yeah
Sparks yeah
I guess because of that though it led me
to this right wanting to teach kids
because I [__] hate teaching kids but
you hate teaching kids if I took this
opportunity I was like oh maybe life is
teaching me to
try this Venture yeah
you're the one that can help them that's
yeah more than just teaching kids
because I can probably I can relate why
you're doing that yeah yeah that's crazy
because all the techniques that we were
taught I mean that was normal
that was [__] up but that was what
everyone was being taught like we all
have a similar history of like yeah we
got our asses it's a sign of the times
to learn how to play piano yeah now if
you do it you're like what kind of
Barbarian are you the [__] is wrong with
you yeah we didn't have Twitter to
complain about it back in the day you
know what I'm saying nothing get away
with that [__] we just talked to other
kids like damn that was hard honey that
was hard yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was
so normal back then but here's the thing
about the generation gap like this is
one way that you guys grew up but now
the generation that's growing up some of
them are too soft a little bit like you
know if I've had times like you know I'm
teaching dance and stuff and these kids
like you tell them a correction and I
even say it nice I'm very compassionate
like with kids but you know if I have to
have a serious Moment Like get them into
shape they can't take anything because
they're really soft and everyone gets a
trophy now over here you gotta move your
arm like this they start crying
sometimes sometimes you'll believe it so
it's like it's like they're missing a
little bit of that push that they need
because if you just baby a kid you know
they're not gonna
do what you're doing and go out and do
all these things with your life and like
take your career to the next level
everything's kind of handed to them
that's not every case but God walk down
here tell me all I gotta do is strip my
kid naked beat him a couple times with a
[__] iron and he'll be Michael
Jackson
[Laughter]
which is that the end of the video
if that's what it takes because that's
all I saw I saw so that's what it takes
to make the best child in the world like
given Michael Jackson's whole life story
would you guys want to make a Michael
Jackson I want to be the Michael Jackson
because I got the same [__] abuse
without the [__] stardom in power
yeah and the money what if Joe Jackson
didn't do that I know it's wrong but
what if he didn't do that to him and
then Michael just decided he didn't want
to do music and then it was just he
could have been a lawyer it'd just be
the Jackson four and I mean obviously
don't abuse but like the Jacksonville if
you just
went on that's the only difference
they're like I don't hear the highest
note where is it there's supposed to be
a solo here what's going on he was just
doing that to test his ring all the
songs are identical one less part
foreign
[Music]